all right this sunday
two will get in and one will go home
rams
bears cardinals and the rams and
cardinals play the winner will have a
playoff
berth it's that simple the loser will
need
help the rams get in if the bears lose
and the bears get in
if the cardinals lose of course the
easiest way for the bears to get in is
just beat the package for the rams
it will be john walford at quarterback
because jared goff
had surgery on his thumb it was the same
doctor
who did the surgery last year on drew
brees thumb
so uh breeze missed five games
jared goff could be back for the
playoffs according to his head coach
sean mcvay that would be surprising if
it happens
but uh look here comes walford and there
was a rams quarterback that no one had
heard of in 1999 who replaced trent
greene and i remember thinking in the
preseason after green had suffered a
torn acl
when he took a low hit from our good
friend rodney harrison that
the rams are done not that anybody
expected anything out of the rams there
was kind of a hey maybe the rams are on
to something here because they have
trent green and they have marshall falk
and maybe it's
you know maybe it's gonna work and the
air went out of the balloon with that
well here comes kurt warner
so you take sean mcvay an offensive
genius
you give him a quarterback that he's
been working with all year long
who knows maybe they'll cook something
up and maybe they'll have some success
and if this
team has built chris on running game and
defense it's not like john walford has
to go out and do a whole lot and based
on what we've seen from jared goff it's
a low bar frankly
to to match what goff's done this season
well yeah i don't you know they're not a
team where we look there and just go oh
it's all about the quarterback and that
the quarterback has to play at a high
level for them to win football games we
know that's not the case
you know it is they are a running
defensive football team and when they've
lost games it's because they've not been
able to run and they've had a throw and
they're not capable of making enough
plays that way and you know
jared goff's had his issues jared goff
tough as hell i do want to say that i
mean
for him to hang in there and play the
other day there is something to say
about that
definitely but i think the overall
formula for which
how the rams play on the offensive side
of the ball it's not going to change one
bit
you're still going to see the same look
rams seeing john walford
he's a pretty good athlete he's got
pretty good control of the ball
saw him on the field a few years ago at
notre dame when when he came in there as
the wake forest starting quarterback
you know can move around well's going to
be able to do all the boots and play
action stuff that they need him to do
so i don't really think they're gonna
miss anything
you know other than i think here's the
big thing yeah he hasn't played all year
so now he's playing in a big football
game
against the arizona cardinals they got
to protect him early
especially just don't put him in any
situation to where he can make a mistake
and end up
screwing your season over because now
hey we got a guy that we asked to do
something a little too aggressive here
and we've thrown two interceptions and
we're down 14 nothing and might not go
to the playoffs
and they might not have you know the
check with me's at the line of scrimmage
right mike that's probably where they're
gonna have to dial it back a little bit
where goff and mcvay have this great
you know hey you've got two or three
plays called and here we go let's get up
the line of scrimmage and you figure it
out real quick they'll probably dial
that back a little bit
but i think all in all it's still going
to look the same to us as viewers on tv
you know whose backup's going to be on
sunday don't you
blake bortles coming to save the day
uh look the fact that bortles was the
backup
last year and the rams let him leave
without even batting an eye
i think already tells us everything we
need to know at this point this is just
here's a guy
who number one has a pulse and number
two
knows the offense right i don't think
they have a whole lot of faith in blake
bortles or he'd have been the backup and
he'd be the guy getting the start on
sunday
so it's john walford who has kind of
bounced around the nfl and he played in
the aaf
he's never thrown a a regular season
pass in the nfl but he did have 14
touchdown passes in the truncated
only aaf season of 29
so he's got playing experience just not
at this level and not at these stakes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports